[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avec son maître 78 et c'est 100 kg David
Cruciani possède à peu près les
dimensions d'un frigo
[Musique]
sur Tik Tok il compte un million et demi
d'abonnés son secret se greffer sur la
traîne comprenez la tendance virale du
moment
[Musique]
ça a commencé je crois que c'était
pendant juste avant le confinement en
fait il y avait une traîne qui était
sortie c'était un son d'un artiste NASA
je crois que c'était joli bébé et puis
du coup j'ai une idée je dis je
regardais un peu les vidéos de tout le
monde il y a personne qui l'a fait avec
son animal de compagnie donc du coup
j'ai un chien je me suis dit allez je
vais le faire avec mon chien et donc
j'ai posté cette vidéo et en 48 heures
j'ai eu mes 10000 abonnés
et du coup moi je me suis pas pourquoi
pas on continue donc du coup je continue
en un an je suis monté un million un
million 1 million d'abonnés
12 ans d'effort pour en arriver à ce
corps de culturiste 6 jours
d'entraînement par semaine une
alimentation très surveillée parce que
la salubrité c'est comme les muscles ça
n'arrive pas tout seul bonjour la team
je suis avec l'équipe de France 3 entre
les tournages le montage et les
diffusions en direct David passe jusqu'à
5 heures par jour à alimenter ses
nombreux réseaux sociaux vous fait des
gros gros bisous
partout snapchat Instagram je me suis
lancé sur YouTube
Twitter Tik Tok enfin voilà je suis
parti
[Musique]
technicien dans la vraie vie les réseaux
sociaux pourraient ouvrir à David les
portes d'une nouvelle carrière moi je ne
vis pas de ça non moi si tu veux c'est
pas vraiment une pression pour moi moi
j'ai mon travail à côté mais si
quelqu'un n'a pas de travail vit que des
réseaux là oui je peux comprendre que
c'est une pression moi c'est je le fais
pas vraiment par passion quoi
mais à 29 ans la célébrité ne lui a pas
fait tourner la tête beaucoup de jeunes
sont vraiment pense qu'au réseau sociaux
et c'est ça peut être dangereux des fois
ça peut vraiment être dangereux faire
attention il faut rester les pieds sur
terre
[Musique]
n'a pas les dimensions d'un frigo c'est
normal il est mannequin
avec 5000 abonnés sur Instagram il
commence à se faire un nom sur les
réseaux au programme aujourd'hui séance
photo au profit d'une campagne contre
les discriminations
et pour être pris au sérieux le moindre
détail compte
ah ouais
comme ça
[Musique]
harceler depuis l'école primaire
aujourd'hui Jérémy partage sa vie en
ligne avec des internautes pas toujours
bienveillants enfin c'est des injures
raciales parfois c'est pas par rapport à
mon orientation sexuelle parfois c'est
par rapport à tout simplement mes choix
de vie oui ça peut être très très
violent là comme ça
s'il sofa oui
à deux vies bien séparé d'un côté sa
famille son compagnon son jardin secret
de l'autre les réseaux sociaux et les
projecteurs
quand j'allais mal ou quand j'étais
harcelé ou quand j'étais victime
et bien moi je m'empressais de partager
ça peut-être avec les internautes de
partager ça avec les journalistes un peu
comme une thérapie justement mais
peut-être pas forcément avec ma propre
famille donc forcément quand après il
prenait conscience des sujets des soucis
parce qu'ils ouvraient un journal etc
sur le net il voyait ce que j'avais pu
vivre là ça a été un peu compliqué
[Musique]
à 18 ans tout juste bachelière encore
chez ses parents pauline est une jeune
femme comme les autres sauf qu'elle est
à 500 000 abonnés sur Tik Tok
elle publie trois vidéos par jour son
planning est très simple
[Musique]
ça dépend vraiment en fait si c'est un
soir de semaine scolaire un mercredi
après-midi le weekend en période
scolaire c'est plus du 13h 17h21 un
vendredi soir un samedi un dimanche soir
à 15h soit à 17h ensuite vers 18h30 19h
en période scolaire vers 18h et le
mercredi après-midi j'essaye de poster
une fois dans l'après-midi parce que
souvent les gens ils sont pas court
l'après-midi et pareil le vendredi soir
on peut essayer de gratter un peu
jusqu'à 21h
mais cet emploi du temps surchargé ne
gênant rien la poursuite de ses études
Pauline vient d'entrer en BTS
Communication
Tik Tok du coup pour moi c'est plus un
loisir parce que j'ai le plaisir en fait
d'avoir d'avoir continué mes études au
lycée parce que ça reste quand même une
partie une plus grande partie de ma vie
sociale que de d'être sur Tik Tok enfin
j'ai mes amis j'ai mes sorties j'ai tout
ça j'ai en fait j'ai une vie vraiment à
côté de Tik Tok et Tik Tok c'est
vraiment un plus
devant ce succès les parents de Pauline
sont un peu dépassés je m'en suis
aperçue quand on est parti en vacances
et que on se baladait en famille et que
il y avait plein de jeunes filles dans
la rue qui se retournaient et qui
chuchotaient et qui était toute rouge
toute gêné et donc je regarde Pauline et
Pauline m'a dit bah oui ben c'est c'est
pour moi en fait maman voilà donc là
j'ai commencé à me dire on n'est pas à
la maison on n'est pas en Touraine on
est vraiment ailleurs et il y a des
jeunes filles qui sont même allés
jusqu'à repérer des photos de
l'appartement dans lequel on était et
qui sont venus en bas à appeler Pauline
donc c'est là où on se dit quand même
que voilà il se passe quelque chose en
tout cas
ces contrats avec des marques rapportent
à Pauline un petit revenu l'équivalent
d'un job d'été
[Musique]
Thierry gradoni et l'agent de plusieurs
stars des réseaux sociaux trouver des
partenariats c'est son job
Pauline qui est juste là vous arrivez
directement sur son compte Tik Tok donc
après vous voyez on va regarder on a à
la rencontre Cohen donc elle adore les
les stars des séries elle en fait
beaucoup d'ailleurs même dans ces dans
ces partenariats à regarder par exemple
celui-ci donc le partenariat on peut on
peut on le voit très discrètement mais
là elle fait des tenues en fonction des
stars séries elle est susceptible de
rencontrer se mettre en avant au
quotidien
face à sa communauté l'affaire évoluer
aussi sa communauté parce que la
communauté vieillit avec vous c'est pas
évident faut qu'elle adhère toujours à
votre à votre identité oui il faut une
grande forme de maturité est très jeune
l'agence de Thierry encadre une
trentaine d'influenceurs de 14 à 23 ans
autant de personnages dont la vie fait
rêver après attention les réseaux
sociaux c'est une facette de la personne
on voit pas le quotidien parfois il est
totalement différent
bonjour bienvenue chez moi Jérémy lui ne
tombe jamais le masque ça on va faire un
premier tri après on va envoyer ça en
post prod et en retouche ça a aussi elle
est bien
chez lui il nous reçoit entouré de son
équipe
c'est un besoin vital pour ne pas se
retrouver seul face à lui-même
je suis jamais seul etc c'est parce que
j'ai un manque que je ne peux pas
combler c'est parce que j'ai un des
fêlures également anciennes qui ne sont
pas réparés je dois avoir un entourage
un compagnon j'ai beau avoir des amis ça
ne remplacera peut-être pas tous
cette haine que j'ai pu recevoir je suis
aussi abandonnée quand j'étais petit
adopté c'est mes parents ils m'ont donné
beaucoup d'amour mais pas l'amour
peut-être que j'aurais pu avoir donc je
pense que ce qu'on peut souhaiter au
Jérémy plus tard c'est peut-être en
accord avec soi-même être en paix et
être serein et heureux
[Musique]
en seul Lançon sur Tik Tok Pauline a dit
adieu à son anonymat et à une certaine
tranquillité
[Musique]
en bas de l'appartement où on habitait
en vacances moi j'ai moi ça va faire un
peu peur en fait j'avais juste mis une
story en face de la merde où on
appartement et en fait on voyait que
c'était un balcon en forme de bateau et
en fait c'est un
genre d'appartement qui est un peu connu
à Saint-Raphaël et du coup bah ils sont
arrivés le soir en bas
moi ça va mes parents ils trouvent ça
drôle moi j'étais en mode
bah ouais je suis en train de déjeuner
avec ma famille à des gens en bas qui
disent ouais c'est là qu'elle habite
Pollux non au secours
la notoriété de Pauline ne lui a pas
apporté que des amis au lycée elle a
connu le harcèlement et elle en garde
des cicatrices
quand on m'avait pollu que j'ai
l'impression que les gens sont là que
pour Paulux du coup et c'est pour ça que
j'aime pas qu'on m'appelle comme ça
parce que quand je me dis que des gens
qui ont pu m'embêter avant
se permettre en fait de m'appeler
polluxe en rigolant je me suis dit qu'en
fait si les gens m'appellent comme ça
c'est vraiment qui me voient que par
cette image là car derrière Pollux il y
a Pauline
de savoir en fait que j'ai des amis
autour de moi je suis assez douteuse en
fait dans la vie je suis naïve je suis
douteuse en fait genre c'est une partie
fragile de moi en fait que je monte pas
sur les réseaux sociaux parce que bah ça
sert à rien mais c'est vrai que par
derrière heureusement que j'ai des amis
du coup parce que c'est
[Musique]
compliqué
et si jamais demain Tik Tok de veste
j'ai quand même mes études à côté donc
en soit j'ai mes potes mais j'ai mes
études j'ai de quoi faire une vie donc
David aussi a construit sa vie
et son refuge c'est sa femme et son fils
[Musique]
mais avec la célébrité viennent les
insultes et le harcèlement
et malheureusement sur les réseaux il y
a beaucoup beaucoup de gens qui sont
juste là pour insulter moi j'ai eu des
menaces de mort j'ai eu
tout honnêtement dans la vraie vie il y
a personne qui va m'embêter tu vois
c'est juste des gens d'Internet
mais les gens d'ailleurs un écran se
sentent pousser des ailes quoi
ces menaces n'atteignent pas David mais
elle vise parfois sa famille
alors ça quand tous qu'on ose insulter
un enfant qui vient un enfant à
nourrisson qui vient de demander ok
c'est on a fait une vidéo parce que ma
femme elle est enceinte tout le monde a
suivi un peu l'histoire de ma femme qui
est vécu l'histoire entre guillemets
qu'elle était enceinte donc on a Monte
on a montré vu un peu notre fils sur les
réseaux mais sans plus tu vois et il y a
quand même des gens qui sont capables
d'insulter un enfant enfin voilà
même pas de terme pour pour le décrire
quoi qu'est-ce qu'ils ont dit
la gueule de
du nourrisson vu la gueule du père et de
la mer voilà enfin c'est bon quoi
il y en a plein je veux regarder sur les
vidéos enfin mais il y en a beaucoup
beaucoup de commentaires quoi après j'ai
hyper dur là de pas répondre tu vois
c'était hyper dur mais dans ma tête je
me dis il faut surtout pas que je
réponde
[Musique]
et si face à la haine sur les réseaux
sociaux la meilleure réponse c'était
juste de se déconnecter